es momento de que pausa es el vídeo y
encuentres la suma de estas dos
expresiones racionales
bien suponiendo que ya lo hiciste vamos
a trabajarlo juntos y lo primero que
seguramente notas de cuando intentaba
resolverlo es que podemos ver que
tenemos diferentes denominadores y no es
tan fácil sumar fracciones con distintos
denominadores así que será mejor
reescribir cada una de estas expresiones
racionales para tener un denominador
común y la forma más sencilla de obtener
un denominador común es simplemente
multiplicar los dos denominadores
iniciales y especialmente en casos
cuando no tienes factores en común es
decir cuando observas todos los factores
de cada uno de los denominadores y ves
que no tienes ningún factor en común así
que vamos a resolver esto que tenemos
aquí así que qué te parece si escribimos
todo con base en nuestro denominador
común y nuestro denominador común va a
ser 2x menos 3 por 3 x + 1 así que
déjame ponerlo con este color
x menos 3 esto lo voy a poner con color
azul y con otro color se me ocurre es te
voy a poner 3 x + 1 así que me va a
quedar álbum entre nuestro denominador
común o algo entre nuestro denominador
común ya esto le vamos a sumar déjame
ponerlo con color amarillo a esto le
vamos a sumar algo que tiene que ver
también con nuestro denominador común
así que le vamos a sumar algo que va a
ser dividido entre 2 x menos 3 esto a su
vez que multiplica a 3 x + 1 a 3 x + 1
y bueno quiénes son esos algo de lo que
hablamos bueno para eso vamos a fijarnos
primero en nuestra primera expresión
esta que tengo aquí si observas ya tengo
aquí es de 2 x menos 3 en mi denominador
y para pasar de 2 x menos 3 a 2 x menos
3 x 3 x más uno observa que
multiplicamos por 3 x 1 así que si
estamos multiplicando el denominador por
3 x + 1 vamos a hacer lo mismo para el
numerador así que me voy a tomar este 5x
lo voy a atrapar con este color me voy a
tomar a este 5x y lo voy a poner aquí 5
x que multiplica quien bueno va a
multiplicar a 3 x + 1 va a multiplicar a
3 x
1 ojo observa que estoy multiplicando y
dividiendo por 3 x 1
así que 3 x 1 / 3 x 1
es lo mismo que 1 y solamente me
quedarían con 5 x entre 2 x menos 3 que
era mi expresión original así que lo
único que estoy haciendo es
multiplicando por 1 y además si
multiplicó el denominador por 3 x 1
también multiplicó el numerador por 3 x
1 y va a pasar lo mismo con la siguiente
expresión con esta que tengo aquí
observa que ya tengo este 3 x 1 déjame
ponerlo con su respectivo color este de
aquí es este de aquí y ahora tengo que
multiplicar este menos 4 x cuadrada
déjame ponerlo así menos 4 x cuadrada a
éste lo voy a multiplicar por quién
bueno observa que si el denominador lo
estamos multiplicando por 2 x menos 3
entonces también voy a hacer lo mismo
para el numerador lo voy a multiplicar
por 2 x menos 3 y de nuevo observa 2 x
menos 3 entre 2 x menos 3
sencillamente 1 así que mi expresión
original
la estoy multiplicando por 1 y ahora sí
puedo escribir todo esto que tengo aquí
de la siguiente manera en el numerador
que me va a quedar bueno con este color
observa que voy a multiplicar primero 5x
por 3 x 1 pero tengo que distribuir este
5x y entonces me va a quedar 5 x x 3 x
eso es lo mismo que 15 x cuadrada y
después tengo 5 x x 1 es 5 x 5 x muy
bien por otra parte tengo esto de aquí
menos 4 x cuadrada que multiplica a 2 x
menos 3 así que también voy a distribuir
este menos 4 x cuadrada para que
multiplique primero a 2 x y después a
menos 3 y bueno menos 4 x cuadrada x 2 x
eso es lo mismo que menos
8x kubica muy bien y después menos por
menos es más 4 por 3 es 12 12 x cuadrada
x cuadrada ok y todo esto lo voy a
dividir todo esto lo voy a dividir entre
nuestro denominador común que ya sabemos
que es 2 x menos 3 esto que a su vez
multiplican a 3 x + 1 lo voy a poner así
3 x + 1 muy bien ahora te puedes dar
cuenta que podemos reducir un poco acá
arriba así que vamos a hacerlo si
observas déjame ponerlo con este color
lo primero que tenemos es este menos 8 x
cúbica así que lo voy a atrapar con su
respectivo color es esta parte de aquí y
la voy a escribir justo aquí a la
derecha menos 8 x kubica
éste no se reduce con nadie pero después
por acá
tengo 15 x cuadrada y también tengo 12 x
cuadrada así que estos dos los puedo
sumar y reducir los 15 x cuadrada + 2 x
cuadrada es lo mismo que 27 27 x
cuadrada de lujo y por último tengo este
5x así que no lo olvidemos más 5 x muy
bien ya todo esto ya todo esto lo voy a
dividir entre el denominador común que
es 2x menos 3 muy bien que multiplica a
3 x + 1
voy a buscar su respectivo color 3 x + 1
y qué creés hemos terminado puedes
observar que aquí en la parte de arriba
podemos factorizar todavía una equis
pero si la factory zam os no se ve de
alguna manera que podamos reducir más
términos y simplificar más esta
expresión racional así que ya está hemos
acabado